[Musique]
on l'attend
en thaïlande ce sont des images de moins
en moins rare
des tigres au coeur de la nature filmée
ici par les caméras de surveillance
installées en pleine forêt le royaume
est l'un des rares pays au monde où leur
population ne cesse d'augmenter
alors que l'espèce est aujourd'hui
décimé au cambodge au laos au vietnam
mais pour sauver ce tigre la thaïlande
navigue aujourd'hui entre protection et
exploitation de l'espèce
ce matin là nous patrouillons dans ce
parc national avec l'une des
vingt-et-une équipe de rangers chargé
ici de protéger l'espèce
cette unité a été spécialement formés
pour suivre les faits la trace
30 cm 30 cm de large
voici des traces dans tigre hill à
gratter la terre ici pour marquer son
territoire maintenant c'est sa zone de
chasse
lors de relever et la position gps des
traces sont consignés dans ces carnets
de bord
chaque équipe doit faire savoir où il y
a des traces de tigres ça nous permet de
déterminer des zones précises où il faut
multiplier nos patrouilles pour mieux
protéger l'espèce
pour les aider dans leur mission les
rangers dispose désormais de 500 caméras
de surveillance
elles permettent notamment de repérer la
présence de braconniers comme ici ces
deux hommes en armes qui seront arrêtés
peu après
les braconniers chasse le tigre
notamment pour sa peau qui sert de
décoration
ce sont parfois des gens riches qui vont
accrocher une tête de tigre comme
trophées de chasse ça leur permet de
montrer leur puissance
grâce aux patrouilles et aux caméras de
surveillance le nombre de tigres a
presque doublé ici
passants selon les rangers de 40 de fela
en 2010 à plus de 80 aujourd'hui pour un
total de 200 tirs dans tout le pays
alors la thaïlande serait-elle devenue
un modèle mondial pour la protection de
cette espèce en danger
il faut aller dans les zones
touristiques du pays comme ici à pattaya
pour découvrir une toute autre réalité
en plein coeur de la ville voici le
trailer park un parc d'attractions
entièrement consacré aux tigres
allez-y le pouce levé
asseyez vous
et avec l'autre main vous pouvez toucher
levante
pour 50 euros par personne chaque
touriste peut se faire photographier
sous toutes les coutures avec des tigres
de tous les âges
j'ai déjà vu des tigres à la télévision
mais là c'est la première fois que je
peux les toucher c'est tellement mignon
c'est mieux de les avoir ici dans des
cages dans la nature ils font peur aux
jambes
des propos qui peuvent choquer
loin de toute considération pour le
bien-être animal
ici dès que les tigres ont deux ou trois
mois ils sont traités comme des animaux
domestiques
bruce est normal de jouer avec des
tigres normal de jouer vous savez je
suis une amoureuse des chiens et des
animaux si je pouvais passer toute la
journée ici je le ferai
chaque tigre encore ses griffes mais
elles ont été limé et les félins ne sont
pas drogué nous assure la direction du
parc
les 80 tigre sont nés en captivité il se
reproduise ici mais pour les
responsables
ce n'est pas juste du business
notre but c'est de sauver la population
de tigres et de laisser les gens
s'approchaient d'eux comme ça ils
peuvent apprendre comment ils vivent
mais vous avez vraiment l'impression de
sauver ses tigres oui parce qu'on a de
plus en plus de tigres on vient
d'ailleurs d'ouvrir un nouveau parc à
phuket
des parcs comme celui ci il en existe
aujourd'hui plusieurs en thaïlande
pour ce défenseur de la cause animale le
royaume tient un double discours sur la
question de la protection des tigres
c'est de l'exploitation animale
c'est juste purement pour l'argent on a
plus de 2000 tigres en captivité
aujourd'hui en thaïlande alors qu'on a à
peine 200 qui sont sauvages
mais ça à quoi ça sert ce n'est pas du
tout la protection animale la thaïlande
fait un excellent travail pour protéger
les tigres sauvages donc on devrait se
débarrasser de ça
entre protection et exploitation animale
la thaïlande semble donc aujourd'hui ne
pas vouloir choisir